[Music]
Jacque Sparkle class cursed us or
dentists I will have my revenge
[Music]
it's time to hunt a pirate
just borrow cocktails
ready pg-13 tickets available now
[Music]
pirates had infected the seas for
generations
so I'll eliminate them all and then
there was this boy
yes but room
follow him in
he took everything from me
and feet
Rache
[Applause]
the dead I've taken come on girl
I've heard stories
the mighty Spanish captain whose son to
be killed thousands of men no no no men
no no pirates pirates I once knew his
finger than something in Spanish
he's clean future
personal [ __ ] the crew
your pants Jackie I'm so sorry we're
still talking there's no word hide
find Spyro for me
from this moment on we ought to be
allies
chittering where your left hand is I
said we're more than that
Oh
[Music]
I'm not looking for trouble horrible way
to lean
for what you did
I'm in on that show are looking for
jackets I'm going to swim for it Karina
stop this no no no no that's okay this
has gone far enough
no it has not I saw our ankles you
descend a lot more if you kept your
cakehole shot
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you
[Music]